okay so today we're starting emanuel
kant we're going to spend two days on
him and we're getting close to finishing
up
with our intro to philosophy semester
we're moving very quickly kant is
squarely in the middle of the modern era
descartes was at the start descartes was
one of the fathers of modern philosophy
and they're both about equal in
importance
kant is important both for metaphysics
and epistemology on one side and for
moral theory so not just ethics but also
politics and actually he wrote some
important things about aesthetics as
well we're only going to scratch this
and i'm also having my ethics class
reading this this same entry so i'm
going to be videotaping that as well
but we're going to be approaching it
from a different angle than they are
we're going to talk a bit about ethics
but we're going to try to figure out
this question right here
calls this work that we're reading the
groundwork for the metaphysics of morals
and groundwork means think about you
know when you build a house you have to
build a foundation first if you don't
build a foundation what happens to the
house
what happens
yeah it'll fall apart i mean sooner or
later right it may stand up at first but
sooner or later it's gonna it's gonna
collapse
so you have to have a good foundation
and it's the same thing in philosophy
you want to have a good starting point
that's what kant views himself as doing
here and remember descartes did the same
thing too right he doesn't want to wipe
away all his previous opinions
and then see what could stand the test
of
a hyperbolic doubt
kant is taking a different approach
but he's making another departure
so groundwork for the metaphysics of
morals what could that possibly mean the
metaphysics of morals
what do you remember about this term
metaphysics what is that about
that's the part of philosophy that does
what
confuses people
it is the toughest part of philosophy
actually um aerosol thought so there's
some other metaphysicians like like
heidegger
what is metaphysics about
that you can recall
you have some metaphysical beliefs
what can you remember what what what
topics does it deal with
some of the really deep stuff right
do you remember anything offhand
what are what are some of the yeah i
don't know if i'm going to write or not
but i think it's something related like
with what happens after we die like
yeah you know
that's not part of it that we touched on
but that would be part of metaphysics
is there something like a soul that
survives past the destruction of the
body that's that's a metaphysical
question you're right
um
how is the soul connected to the body
that would be another metaphysical
question there we're dealing with a
special part of metaphysics called the
metaphysics of the human person
you know
what is metaphysics about
so it's about us right but it's also
about things like this
what do all the things have in common
what do you have in common with this
thing other than you might be wearing
blue
which only applies to a few of you
kind of a hard question to unpack isn't
it what do you have in common with a pen
or this desk here
or
this word manual written on the
chalkboard
do you have anything in common with them
it's really not your height
weight
gender
age
it's not even your
your form is it
all of you have the same form of human
being in common with each other and with
me
but what do you have in common with a
pen
well you exist right
you're a being
remember when we did the four clauses we
can do the four clauses for you and we
can do it for
this dossier here we can do it for the
pen we can do it for
a song that we can only hear not see
metaphysics deals with being
and so we can look at what is the being
of
a human person but that just makes this
even more confusing doesn't it
so the metaphysics of morals when you
read khan
there at least this selection did that
strike you as being about metaphysics or
that strike you as being about ethics
what is ethics about
right and what's the right and wrong or
good and bad right um
good and evil
sometimes we use those terms
um even things like just and unjust or
noble or base those are matters of
ethics
so what would a metaphysics of ethics
look like maybe that's like blurring
together two things that can't get mixed
like oil and water
you know it's not like peanut butter and
jelly or peanut butter and chocolate
where they enhance each other's taste
well
kant is kind of confusing here
metaphysics of morals would really be a
metaphysics of the human being who you
are
what kind of thing you are with respect
to
what else is ethics about it's not just
about good and bad it's about
what else
what do you use ethical language to talk
about
what do you call good and bad
what's that
what do you call right and wrong though
good or bad right and wrong what you
know you use those words all the time
what do you use them for
what do you what do you
predicate them of
probably not a pen right this is this is
a right pen i mean it could be the right
pen for
a job i guess if what you really want is
a blue pen
what do we what do we use ethical
language about
what do you think is good and bad
people
okay yeah what makes a person good or
makes a person bad
their actions right so
when we talk about the metaphysics of
morals we're looking at the human being
as an acting thing
remember we did some of this before when
we looked at aristotle and are you
really free
when you do actions
if the action has its origin in you it's
causing you then then aristotle says
you're free if it has its cause say in
compulsion like i make you do the action
because i have a joystick that taps into
your brain and you know makes you do
things
um why you come in and i play a song
that makes you go crazy and you know
do all sorts of bizarre things then
you're not responsible for your actions
and then you know it doesn't make sense
to call you good or bad
if you're not responsible for your
actions does it
so
we are doing ethics
but we're doing ethics in part to try to
learn some more things about who we are
at least according to kant
here's where we get to some of these
these questions
and
we're going to use this as an example
before we go into all this stuff about
the good bill and duty and
categorical imperatives and all that
let's just think about thanksgiving
so
we're going to put two columns happiness
and duty
who is happy over thanksgiving break
not everybody
okay good that's everybody was
so what made you happy
what things made me happy well i saw a
lot of my friends the first time in a
while okay yeah and that that's that's
important this is probably the first
real
break that you got wasn't it um we had
that
mid-semester break and it was only for
like a couple days i think
per day so
what should we call that um
well we'll
use the use exactly the same thing
seeing
friends again
what else yeah food
food yeah i hope that you guys had some
good food because that was uh the whole
point of
well it's not the whole point of
thanksgiving but it's pretty close right
yeah
yeah
um let me put that over here because
that's very similar right
family
um yeah sleeping in my own bed oh that's
interesting
yeah
let me put that here and let's think a
little bit more about that
in
on bed again
i guess we would
would call that sort of
resuming the familiar or
getting back to where you feel like you
you belong
right uh what else
yeah
i suppose you do have to do that here so
that you don't get a
athlete's foot right
or who knows what else
yeah not having to
let's broaden that to say take certain
precautions
because if you live in the dorms
i suppose there's probably some things
you have to keep locked up too right
otherwise they might disappear
but you don't have to do that at home i
hope
unless you really don't trust your
relatives
anything else
we can think of
my fiance and i were actually very happy
because we watched the game
and of course there was only one game as
far as you know she and i were concerned
that was the packers game it was a very
close game and then they beat the lions
and so we'll you know we'll just call
that sport right there was other things
like that or sport or
entertainment
can any of you see movies
over thanksgiving
nobody saw a movie or watched a tv show
or
what else people do for entertainment
i'm sure some of you played games
right else do we do
go to
hear bands or
things like that
okay so this is a good list we'll come
back to that in a minute what about
duties did you did any of you have any
duties things that you
felt like you had to do
and you may not have wanted to do them
necessarily but
somebody was counting on you to do
what you felt to be the right thing yeah
okay
yeah that's probably a pretty common one
right
that's a lot of cooking
right
um depends on how big your family is if
you're at my family that's a lot of food
yeah
yeah that there's the other
part of it
help
clean up
um
anything else does anybody have any
relatives who are
who are older who are
say having trouble getting around or
anything like that
sometimes you have to help out a little
bit
anybody have any relatives like that
yeah
well i wouldn't say that but i mean i
had to help my grandparents like
you know carry stuff from their car i
guess okay
um
let's just call that helping the agent
with uh
taxes
and you know hopefully as you get older
you got somebody to do that for you all
right that's
one reason you want to
make sure that you do it when you're
young
what else anything else you felt like
you want to do over that
break did any of you feel like you had
any responsibilities to yourself
i mean you've put in a lot of time
this is
what week 14 of the semester
you've gone to college you settled in
for some of you it's been you know more
more comfortable for some of you it's
probably been uncomfortable in parts and
you slide through you notice some of
your classmates aren't here
they didn't they didn't actually make it
through
but you did
so you reached kind of a milestone you
made it to thanksgiving break
do you think that
i don't know it's not just about does
that give you the right to do something
do you feel like you have any duties to
yourself
yeah
to finish up
yeah well that yeah but you didn't do
that over thanksgiving did you know but
what did you do
i think that you could actually make an
argument that one of the things that you
ought to have done over thanksgiving
drake
is
taking it easy and refreshed yourself
and
gotten yourself back up to par
because you know the next two weeks are
probably going to be
a bit tougher because you have a lot of
assignments coming due right and you're
getting ready for final exams again for
your first first year in college
um
you're probably went home you're
probably a little homesick now now that
you actually got to see home again
no
um
so you know taking some time to actually
rest yourself up that could actually be
a duty
to yourself you can have duties to
yourself
taking care of yourself can be a duty
um
what else is there anything else that
you felt you ought to do over
over break
i know one that almost all of you did
put a paper and i learned right
you have to need an assignment
anything else that you guys felt that
you should do that you have
sort of an obligation to do
that you can think of
did you visit with anybody that you
didn't really feel like visiting with
why did you do it
that's a good question
how many of you did visit with somebody
whose company
ordinarily would not have sought out
just a few of you
um
there could be all sorts of reasons for
doing that right what could be some
reasons for doing that yeah they were
with the people that i was with you know
seriously i wasn't
yeah but they were there okay did you
make an effort to talk to them or to
make them feel welcome or anything like
that not really
there could actually be you know you
could feel a duty to
lie
yeah
i'm we're not we're not trying to judge
anybody here we're just sort of like
like laying out what people might have a
feeling that they
they want to do you know some people
actually like go to soup kitchens on
thanksgiving and put in you know a
couple hours helping out why do they do
that do they go because they really like
bums you know can't get enough of them
maybe
maybe some do or do they go because they
help you know makes the thanksgiving
turkey
taste so much better when you experience
poverty for a while before it you know
and see some people are really down and
out there may be some people who
actually do that i don't know
probably not though probably they do it
for for other reasons
because they feel that there's some sort
of
obligation
now
why did i have you you know do this
because for cons
these are very
separate from each other happiness and
duty are
almost disconnected
he will put them back together but this
is very different than aristotle this is
very different than other types of
ethics where happiness is something that
you ought to be seeking out that you
ought to be asking what makes me happy
let's think about why these things make
us happy
um seeing friends again
how many of you did see your old friends
from say high school
everybody huh um
what makes you happy about that
yeah
well it had been a
few months since i'd seen them last
so you missed them
i suppose what did you miss in that one
why why couldn't some people here to
substitute for your friends and you know
just fill in and they'd be just you know
just as good
yeah because you were with him for so
long it's not really a habit but it's
it could you have gotten to know them
better than other people yeah so you can
kind of relate to them when you go back
and talk to them about similar
situations okay so you can relate to
them that that's probably something and
you have a shared history we call that
um
and you enjoy
going back over that and when you talk
to them about new things they know the
back story and your your new friends
here at school don't necessarily know
that
yeah there's something really to that to
that
i just recently got back in touch with a
guy who i haven't seen for 20 years
who's now a blacksmith
which is not surprising because he was
really into swords
and metallurgy back then when i was in
high school with him hasn't kept in
touch with anybody from high school
and so i emailed him
because i've been wondering where he was
and so i looked him up on the web and
there he was
and
we were almost able to pick up
with you know these conversation a
little bit almost as if
the years you know
weren't intervening
that's that's kind of interesting
there's something really there
in your in your makeup when it comes to
why you like being with friends why you
like being with these friends
and that's going to grow for you as you
get older
as you experience more things
what about your family why do you like
seeing your family
is it the same thing as a friends
or is there something different there
i mean you've been with your family
longer than your friends right
but is that all there is
why do you want to be back with your
family
i think all of you do right
i hope
i hope it was good for you
that's something to think about let's
think about the food
um
what did you guys eat i think everybody
probably ate turkey right
what else did you what else do you like
that you had at thanksgiving yeah
potatoes yeah stuffing stuffing those
are
two of the staples yeah
stuffing i bet you guys probably have
different recipes too right
sometimes you get more than one kind of
stuffing if you have a big family
i'm not big on the cranberry stuff but i
know a lot of people like that that sort
of thing
i do like the thing with the
sweet potatoes and the marshmallows on
top and oh
there's probably a lot of other people
here
why do we like that stuff so much
is it just the taste do you think
i mean if it's just the taste you could
have the same meal back in the dorm
couldn't you
maybe that ties in with some of these
things
maybe you actually like
sitting down for turkey because that's
part of your family tradition
sleeping in your own bed again you know
like i said that's a really interesting
one to
to bring up um
i can understand that
basically from from my army days again
going back to
you know my my home and actually being
in familiar setting as opposed to being
in somebody else's
place just sort of renting a spot
um
having to take certain precautions
sports or entertainment now current
would talk about all of these sort of
things
as having to do with what he calls
desires
or inclinations
and every single one of you
is a whole mess of desires and
inclinations
now we talked about this when we looked
at plato right you all have appetites so
you like food
thank god for that because otherwise
you'd be dead
you like being with friends and family
that's good too because otherwise you'd
be a misanthrope and no fun to be with
and you probably couldn't function in
college if you were totally asocial
you know you do take some delight in
entertainment of whatever sort it is
that's good that means you can actually
be with other people and enjoy yourself
but these have to do with a part of you
which is different for each of you
not every not every single one of you
likes the same stuffing
you don't all like the same
entertainment you certainly don't all
like the same friends right and you
certainly don't all have the same family
you can relate to each other
so if i say to you oh i got to see my my
sister and i haven't seen her for a
couple years you can you can relate to
that right because you know what it's
like to have a family member who you
haven't seen for a while
but it's not the same family member and
that the good feeling that i feel
comes from the satisfaction of my
inclinations or my desires
the good feeling that you have
comes from the satisfaction of your
inclinations or your desires whatever
happens to do that for you
now
kant says none of that has any any moral
worth at all
it's good in a way
but there's no moral value to that
what about duties like this
helping to cook or helping to clean up
you know you do it not necessarily
because you want to do it although i
know some people here like to cook
but
you do it because you feel that you you
ought to do it
well now we could have something
that kant would think does have some
moral value
doing what you feel that you ought to do
even when you don't really want to do it
that could actually
be a good thing to do how many of you
have done a lot of things like that in
your life doing things that you know you
should do but you don't really feel like
doing at the time it actually goes
against your
your inclinations or your desires what
kind of things do you do like that
yeah homework yeah that's a great
example why
why do you do homework
there could be a lot of reasons right
what what are
what are some of the reasons you do
homework so i don't get on your back
right
that could be a reason
why else so that we get a good grade in
the class so you get a good grade in the
class um
why do you you know
why do you want that what does a good
grade mean to you
maybe you just have a desire for a good
grade
maybe
getting good grades makes you happy
because it makes you feel like you know
you're achieving something or you're you
know you're a smart person or
you're a hard worker
khan would say if that's the reason that
you're doing that that doesn't actually
have any moral value
could you be doing your your work for
something that would have moral value
why else are you supposed to be
trying to get good grades what is the
grade supposed to be measuring
hopefully it is
why do we give you grades
just to mess with you
some professors do hopefully none of you
had any like that i had some
just to be like a motivator
you know
like a carrot you know you run along
there's your a come chase it come on go
get it go get it and we never quite let
you get it you know a minus
why why do we grade here
here
what are we supposed to be doing
yeah finding out how well we know the
topic we're studying
yeah
excuse me what what level of knowledge
have you acquired
now
that's development of you as a person
and you know again if you i've said this
before if you enter college and then you
come out of here four years later then
you haven't had any major changes in who
you are
marist hasn't done its job or you
haven't done your job because that
shouldn't be the case you should know a
lot more you should understand a lot
more you should actually have developed
some degree of wisdom
you should have some skills that
employers want you know to hire you for
you should have engaged in some
cultivate what kant would call
cultivation of your talents and
faculties
you should be a better person when you
come out of college than when you enter
better in several different ways
you should probably actually be a better
person morally when you get out of
college than you come in if the college
is doing its job
i'm not sure how many of them are doing
their jobs in that way
at least this place requires you to take
an ethics class you know that's going to
if you have any problems that will
straighten you out right taking an
ethics class
what do you think
maybe not
but
this could be done
these sort of things could be done
out of duty
and not necessarily
just to satisfy your desires and
inclinations kant would say that it
would actually have moral value
that's the difference between doing
something that he says accords with duty
and something that's done from duty
so that leads us into the the
stuff that we're going to look at today
all of this
has to do ultimately with what calls
goodwill
it's not like you know the clothing
store where you take stuff when you
don't want to wear it anymore or you go
to it and buy stuff when you don't want
it that's a different kind of goodwill
that means like being nice to people
that's where we got that from goodwill
you know you give people things out of
goodwill
that's what calls benevolence and we're
going to talk about that later on
but what we mean here is a will that is
actually
motivated
by
beauty
by doing what's right that's another way
to put it
doing
what's right
and
not for
any
other reason
you know think about all the different
reasons people do the right thing
you guys are good examples
you know i've never had a as
well-behaved
set of students as i have in marriage
students and and marist is actually well
known for having students who you give
them the work they'll do it
and they won't be they won't disrupt
your class and they'll raise their hands
and they're all very polite
and that's true that does describe you
guys
um
even when students are in difficulties
that you know they often
you know they phrase there's their stuff
very politely
and that's good but why why do that why
be like that is is it just because
that's that's just the way you were
raised
so it's out of habit
that's not doing the right thing
just for doing the right thing
that's just following along with your
routine right
um or do you do the right thing
sometimes because you want to you want
things to go smoothly
is that is that why we do the right
thing i know i do the right thing
sometimes i want things to go
smoothly especially when i'm you know
irritated with somebody
not not students but you know people
like bureaucrats on the outside yeah one
second
so we might we might do the right thing
because we want you know don't make any
waves right
if you
you don't
if you do the wrong thing people are
going to you know pay attention to that
where are you going to say mr p well i
was going to say doing the wrong thing
usually creates more problems for you
yeah you just do it right the first time
then you don't have to either redo it or
suffer the concept that's true yeah um
so it could be a fear of say punishment
or
or bad consequences to follow that's one
reason people do the right thing
why you know why not cheat on your
spouse
well i mean you shouldn't cheat on your
spouse right
that could be one that could be one way
in which you motivate yourself
it's wrong for me to cheat on my spouse
i'm not going to do it or you might say
well if i cheat on my spouse then i
might get caught and then that'll lead
to all sorts of fights and i don't like
fights and
the person i cheat on might not be that
good anyway
and you know we can you know multiply
all these sorts of things
which would be the moral motivation
which would be the one that exhibits
what khan calls the good will
it wouldn't be the one where the person
says well
you know
i would do it except for all these
things that i'm trying to avoid that's
not actually doing something out of duty
that's not having a good will kahn would
say
what are other reasons people do the
the right thing
are there positive
reasons that people do the
the right thing
like what if you love somebody
or you care about them
and so you want to do the right thing
because when you do it it makes you feel
warm and fuzzy inside to do you know do
the right thing with them
that sounds pretty good doesn't it
sounds better than i'm not gonna i'm
gonna do the right thing so i don't get
caught
and punished
how many of you would say that that's
that's enough to make it a moral action
you do the right thing because you love
another person
one only one person two
three four
five
okay that's that's good
i would actually say that myself but i'm
not a conscience and those of you who
raised your hands you're not conscience
either
because kant would say
even if it's being motivated by you know
feelings of love or good you know
friendship towards somebody or you know
something along those lines sympathy
with them
it's still a matter just of satisfying
your desires
and inclinations when you love somebody
you have an inclination to look at them
in a good way
and to do good things to them
for kant
the good will has to almost not have any
other things coming in from the outside
at all no external motivations
just willing the action because that's
the right thing to do and kant says
that's the only truly good thing in the
universe
a good will
everything else
is good in a way if it's good at all
so let's look at some of the some of the
stuff he talks about he says
nothing nothing possibly can be
conceived in the world or even out of it
which can be called good without
qualification blessing it's up to
goodwill
intelligence
intelligence is
sometimes good sometimes bad how can it
go bad
can intelligence be used for bad ends
yeah
he talks about width
he doesn't actually have humor in mind i
think but
let's think about humor most people like
humor right
you guys like to laugh
life be you know
less enjoyable for you if you didn't get
to laugh at all
i think so too
i think humor is a good thing
aristotle actually thought there was a
virtue of good humor
could humor be used for bad
things actually one of the bad parts
about humor is it's almost always at
somebody's expense isn't it right
what about other things he says
courage
resolution perseverance
those are good too right those are
virtues aren't they
courage
didn't we talk about that with plato and
aristotle a while ago
could courage be used for bad things
hi bless you
how could it be for bad things i saw you
nodding
me
yeah
okay yeah
the the thief
who
actually you know does all these crazy
things that we see in the movies you
know going down on the
wire and all that they're a thief
they're courageous but they're a thief
they're stealing somebody else's things
the murderer
who goes in and you know
kill somebody in a very daring
probably enterprising maybe even
gruesome way
they murdered somebody that's a bad
thing right so courage can be used for
bad ends too
so some of the things that we think are
good some of the things that we talk
about is being part of character could
could actually be used for bad things
common sense
what about what he calls gifts of
fortune
can power be used wrongly anybody ever
had power used on them
exercised on them in ways they didn't
like
i know some of you have because because
we've actually talked about some of the
examples in class of being being a
server
and having people um
treat you badly
right
yeah teachers
yeah we we have power right i get to
grade you
so if i'm a jerk
i could you know
i could just be sadistic and give you
bad grades no matter what you do
or i could um
switch things around you know i'm going
to teach you a lesson the bad students
are going to get great grades and the
great students are going to get bad
grades
or i could you know say well you know an
a gonna cost you
i don't just mean time you know i mean
financial inducements
that would be bad too right
so power can be bad riches can wealth be
used for bad ends
know any examples of that
any celebrities that come to mind where
wealth did not actually
turn out to even make them happy
just screw things up for them
anybody come to mind vegan
sure if you open up people magazine you
can find you know five or six within the
first 10 pages
um
honor
or or respect your reputation could that
be used for something bad
some of you have actually written about
clicks
in your your papers for the semester
what what is a click
i mean you all experience that in my
school right clicks are there other
clicks here on campus probably right who
are you going to say
it's a group of people who only accept
you if you're like them
yeah
and you have to have a certain type of
sometimes you have to dress a certain
way or what else you have to talk a
certain way
like the same things
that can be used for bad right
often it is
it's used to exclude other people
what about health i don't know health is
pretty good
isn't health always good
well i don't know was it good for hitler
to be healthy
would it have been better if he had you
know cancer
died young
probably for a lot of people it would
have been
health may not actually be a good thing
it really depends on who has the health
doesn't it what they what they do with
that
and like kant says you know if you're
healthy and you have power and money it
might actually make you kind of cocky
he talks about it as inspiring pride and
often presumption if there isn't a good
will there to moderate that he's not
saying by the way that any of these are
automatically bad things
he's not saying that you know health is
you know something to be avoided or
wealth is something to be avoided he's
just saying if you don't have a good
will if that part of the person isn't
isn't
you know healthy
then all the other stuff could go wrong
it often does go wrong
so
what makes for a good will let's let's
look at that next he says
good will is good not because of what it
performs or affects
not by its aptness for the attainment of
some proposed end but simply by virtue
of the volition
so it's just what it's willing it's not
that it leads to good consequences
it's not
the end
um you know the
state that it's trying to realize it's
the action itself that it's trying to
will
and
he talks about another thing too when it
comes to happiness
this leads us to sort of a really
interesting insight about human nature
says there's something so strange in
this idea of the absolute value of the
mere will in which no account is taken
of its utility
that notwithstanding the thorough ascent
of even common reason to the idea
a suspicion must arise that it's maybe
just the product of high phone fancy
and we've misunderstood the purpose of
nature in assigning reason
we're all familiar with that faculty
it's what we used to think right as the
governor of our will
this is very similar to what we've been
looking at in other people you know
reason
you know knowing
what we ought to do thinking about you
know what what is best what is what is
second best what is worse what to tell
the will what to do and then the will
ought to do it
why
let me
once again put this
opposition up here
why should reason
tell the will what to do
because it makes us happy
because it's going to lead to
not
playing the fool and you know screwing
things up and ultimately
what is happiness it's
satisfaction
of our desires
and inclinations
um you know aristotle said
when you're happy
i mean he doesn't think happiness is
just playing xbox or something like that
or sitting around drinking beer all day
it's you know virtuous activity with
sufficient means and all that but he
thinks that you know that does satisfy
us happiness makes us happy you know
it's sort of a tautology
happiness puts us happiness is the state
in which we are fulfilled in which our
human nature has been realized
that's what aristotle said
kant is saying something kind of
different
and here's his line of reasoning he says
if the goal was just to satisfy our
desires and inclinations
then
his reason
the will the best way to do that
well i don't know
how many of you have pets
okay what kind of pets have you got
yeah of cats how many how many of you
have cats or dogs
a lot of you right did anybody any of
you have any sort of more exotic animals
like
snakes or what do you have
chickens that's interesting
i remember when i was a kid my uncle
kept that and the roosters are mean
you go after kids you know if you're
only this tall watch out for them
um because you know what what are the
inclinations of a rooster packing people
they like that right
um
are your pets happy
who knows
well i mean you can tell kind of talk i
mean if you beat them
they you're pretty sure they're not
happy why because they they make
terrible noises and they try to if
they're cats or dogs they try to hurt
you back
uh or run away you know i mean we we
have some insight into their their
mentality
are they happy when you feed them
sure are they unhappy when you don't
um
what else do they like you know they
like their beds
some dogs and cats like to watch tv
like our one of our dogs can actually
some of them can't make out what's going
on but one of them actually likes to
watch the nature channel and she's you
know she barks at the animals that she
sees especially if it's a bear
and things like that now what's going on
there those animals don't have the
faculty of reason do they
so what is
they do have wills what is necessitating
their will what is making them do the
sorts of things that they do
do they know to eat things
instinct right and kant talks about that
doesn't he
you know
if if nature had intended us just to do
this just to satisfy our desires and
inclinations
wouldn't it have been better just to
give us a bunch of instincts and forget
this reason stuff
because half the time that gets us in
trouble doesn't it makes us do things we
don't you know we regret later on you
know we see opportunities and we take
them and then they turn out not to be so
hot or sometimes reason actually tells
us no don't pursue what makes you happy
do this stuff over here that we call
duty you know forego your satisfaction
of your desires wouldn't have been
smarter just for god or nature or you
know whatever thing designed us just to
put a bunch of instincts in our our
brain so we automatically pursue what
makes us happy if that was a goal
for us to be happy
i mean we have some instincts right what
are what are the instincts you guys have
that are i hope are all functioning
well
what are your basic desires
they're pretty simple
you all want to eat i hope
and drink
because if you don't you're going to die
you all have you know a sexual instinct
you want to reproduce and you have fun
while you're doing it right
um because that's part of what makes us
what we are right um you have instincts
for
being sociable
more or less
human beings are like that
you know when babies are born
uh in order for a baby to develop a
couple things have to happen it's not so
simple as they just pop out there like a
deer you know we've all seen these
nature films you know the baby cow is
born and it's walking around really soon
human babies in order to develop to make
that big brain
uh work
they need shared gays
they need speech they need to be touched
and they need to see smiling
or else their brains won't develop right
and a lot of them will die if they don't
have touch
because we have substituted
something else for instance
but you know if reason is is our way of
being
that's not a very good way of being if
the whole goal is just to
be happy to satisfy our desires and
inclinations
when you were a kid you had instincts
you know you tasted candy for the first
time and then you really liked it right
that was probably your greatest desire
at one time was to eat candy
that and watch tv probably
or play play nintendo or xbox or
whatever play
but then he got older
and now you guys are at a juncture in
your life
where reason has become very important
for you
you're trying to figure out what what
you should do as a person
you're in a very you know important
time of transition
where
you don't have instincts that tell you
exactly what you ought to do do you
how you want to handle situations
you have to think them out don't you
because sometimes you've actually you
relied on your instincts and you got
yourself in trouble
things didn't pan out the way that you
wanted them to
probably i mean my instinct for
curiosity when i was a kid led me to
stick my finger in a mousetrap
i wanted to see how it would work and
then i found out how exactly how it
works
right
so sometimes our instincts aren't going
to help us
what's reason for that
well
gives us an idea about this and this
tells us this goes back to
the metaphysics of the human person
he says um
we find the more that a cultivated
reason applies itself with deliberate
purpose to the enjoyment of life and
happiness
so much does the man fail of true
satisfaction
if you use your reason
just to try to satisfy your instincts
and your desires and some people do this
they spend all their time trying to
figure out what's going to make me happy
what's going to make me happy
what do i need to get what do i need to
do in order to get that what happens
when you get all that stuff
have any of you ever
had what your heart desire was and then
found out that really wasn't your heart
desire
that it felt empty
that you said now what it could be a
relationship could be
it could have been candy
could have been a new game could have
been
getting an a in a class
um
he says this we must admit there lies at
the root of these judgments the idea
that our existence has a different and
far nobler
for which and not for happiness reason
is properly intended
and which must therefore
be regarded as the supreme condition to
which the private ends of man must for
the most part be
postponed
are we made just to
enjoy ourselves
or are we made for something something
better something higher
what do you guys think
i mean you guys have lived 18 years and
you've done a lot of thinking and
feeling and acting and
reflecting on things
what were you made for
how many of you think that
really life is just about
finding out what you actually like and
then getting yourself what you like
i'm surprised that none of you are
raising your hands because i'm sure some
of you
feel that way and it's natural that you
would
so those of you who don't think that's
just about that what do you think it's
about
what's your life about
what what's motivating you what what do
you care about
would you sacrifice
because you are doing it right now
satisfaction of your desires and
inclinations
right now you could be having dinner
you're already satisfying one of your
desires for a little while
you're taking a philosophy class which
probably half of you had no idea you're
going to have to do before you got to
college
what is your uh
what is your life about
is there is there a higher thing that
you
try to focus yourself on is it a person
is there a person in your life that
you would sacrifice your own happiness
for
that could be a good thing
couldn't it
what else do
people center their lives on
i mean some people do it for just for
money right but that's kind of silly
because that's just means to
attain these things what are some higher
things that people
orient their lives by
because you know if you if you're not
comfortable with saying
none of you are apparently that life is
just about satisfying your desires and
inclinations about being happy in this
sense
then you really want to have some idea
of
what it is that you're shooting for
otherwise you're probably not likely to
get it
you could just have sort of a vague idea
and that would be okay
that there is something bigger and
better out there for you and not yet
know what it is kant is giving you an
answer to that
kant is saying that that's
duty
having the good will
that may not be the answer that
satisfies all of you thomas aquinas had
a different answer do you think do you
remember what his was what was the one
good
that could truly satisfy
it wasn't wasn't wealth it wasn't even
anything of the soul
although we experienced it through the
soul remember what that was
that was on the final so you ought to
know at least in two weeks time right
what did thomas think the highest good
was
give a hint
very much like the word good only one
letter is missing
god right
if you think that god is
being in a relationship with god in some
way or however you want to think of it
is
something beyond this
that could be something like kant's
conception of duty
puts it solely within this world
duty is is
what is going to not it's not going to
make us happy necessarily
but it's going to give you a greater
contentment in doing it because you'll
know that you're actually doing the
right thing so then the question is okay
what are our duties are they things like
you know helping to cook
how do you know what you ought to do as
a human being
khan puts in terms of laws
but they're not like they're not just
laws like you know don't speed
um
what are all other things that i mean we
have laws against killing people or
stealing or things like that but those
are what we call positive laws
those are you got the moral law
the moral law tells you how you ought to
behave
and cut
we're going to get it more into this
next class session
he has a way of formulating this that he
calls the categorical
imperative
and that's a very fancy way of saying
a rule that applies to everybody at
every time
no exceptions that's what categorical
means no exceptions
and imperative is a command you guys
some of you have taken languages like
french or spanish or german
and there's what's called the imperative
tense
with the tense no the imperative mood
sorry for verbs
the imperative is a command so it's a
command that applies to everybody thou
shalt not kill is an example of an
imperative
could that be a duty
sure
not killing people
not doing anything that would lead to
somebody dying
would be a moral duty
what are some other shouts that you can
think of
are the big heavy hitters i know
i'm not thinking the ones like you know
thou shalt you know keep the sabbath
holy and all that
that is pretty much just about religion
but some of the things from what we call
the decalogue the ten commandments those
are
what you know most fit in what khan
calls a categorical imperative what else
does it tell you you're supposed to do
or not do
oh shall not commit to any of his wife
yeah
that's that's not about um
action per se
that's about
um disposition or or
the will right
coveting is a matter of the inside of
the person
coveting means to desire too strong
it doesn't mean you shouldn't desire
anything at all you know
but you know if something is somebody
else's hands off
even in your head that's what it's
saying
there's there's thou shalt not commit
adultery
um that's
don't actually put your hands on
somebody else
and then there's hands off in your head
or in your heart
and
that could be a moral law
right i mean that's something kind of
unusual about
the ten commandments is they they not
only prescribe external action they
actually prescribed how one want to feel
or think or
or desire
are there any other things that that you
should do or shouldn't do
what about say developing your talents
none of you have to be here at marist
right
i i know your your parents probably have
expectations that you stay in college
and make something of yourself
i mean quite frankly you could not do
that couldn't you
you drop out and just
hang out on the beach and
panhandle
some people do that
or you could you know get yourself a
job somewhere where you don't have to do
a lot of thinking
and don't develop your mind anymore
that's an option isn't it you guys have
all chosen not to do that
and i applaud you not to by the way i'm
glad none of you are panhandling um
but
that could be a duty
to develop your talents
you could also get through college and
kind of just you know slough by
quite frankly that's what i did when i
was in college i
i uh didn't really apply myself and i
you know i got good grades because i was
smart
um and i you know i didn't make a lot of
waves and i got through and i got my
degree and i didn't actually start
really working hard until i got into
graduate school and i kind of regret
that now
and i can see what kant's saying
that it would not only would the
consequences have been better for me
that was the right thing to do that was
actually a duty to develop my talents
do you have a duty to help other people
or to be good to other people what do
you think
maybe not in the same same way as like
don't kill people
which is more important not killing
people
to stick with first
what do you think
yeah
yeah don't kill him
that's that's what we call a strict duty
and then kant calls things like being
benevolent being good to other people
meritorious duties there are things that
you ought to do
and
you could again you could do those for
different reasons right you could you
could be good to other people why
because you want to get a reputation for
being the kind of person who's good to
other people you want to run for
political office
or you get a charge out of it when
people you know say thank you to you
well those would all be about oh i
erased it those would all be about
happiness
satisfying your desires and inclinations
being good to other people even when you
don't feel like doing
that would be a matter of duty wouldn't
it
that would be a moral action
which of them do you think develops you
more as a human being
or ties into something more
distinctively human
doing good things to other people
because it comes easy because you enjoy
it or doing good things
even when you don't feel like doing it
what do you think
what's your experience
because you have done some things like
that when you didn't feel like doing it
right somebody told you to do it and at
first you're doing it just to please
that person maybe mom or dad but then
after a while you know you actually
started to realize yeah i probably
should do this because this is the right
thing and i still don't feel like doing
it but i i should do this and then you
did it and then what happened
what did you find out about yourself
did you learn anything in the process
maybe you did but you haven't actually
reflected on it yet
that's actually where we'll leave off
so what we're doing is we're going into
the metaphysics of the human person and
we're doing it through ethics
we're going to look at this categorical
imperative
and it's three formulations in the next
class
in section two in section so i'll see
all of you on thursday